io sono originaria di licata un paese a
pochi chilometri da qui
stavo riflettendo sul fatto che la prima
volta che per partecipare a un evento di
questo tipo non devo prendere in
quest'ordine un autobus un aereo poi
magari un altro autobus un treno il
primo biglietto di andata verso verso il
nord l'ho preso esattamente 11 anni fa
nel 2010 quando ho lasciato il mio paese
per andare a studiare al nord e bologna
lo sappiamo bene da queste parti è una
cosa abbastanza comune alla vigilia di
ogni partenza c'è sempre qualcuno che
ripete un vecchio detto con e shirley
nash che tradotto da siciliano sarebbe
chi va via da casa ha successo
così la partenza diventa una tappa
imprescindibile nello sviluppo personale
e professionale di tantissimi giovani
siciliani
il sud delle isole ogni anno perdono
risorse qualificate e decine di comuni e
vedono dimezzare di anno in anno la
propria popolazione
il quadro diciamo è abbastanza desolante
è già di per sé se non fosse che un paio
d'anni fa si è aggiunto un altro evento
la pandemia da marzo 2020 molti se non
la stragrande maggioranza di noi si sono
ritrovati a lavorare la casa cioè che ha
fatto ritorno in ufficio magari a giorni
alterni munito di mascherine
c'è anche chi però non ha più rimesso
piede nella sua propria nella sua
vecchia la sede di lavoro
la stampa e l'opinione pubblica hanno
parlato genericamente di smart working
ma se ci soffermiamo per un attimo
guardare le nostre nuove quotidianità
lavorative vedremo che di smart c'è
davvero poco
abbiamo piuttosto fatto delle lavoro
emergenziale da casa e in questo caso
non c'è molto di smart
la remotizzazione del lavoro ha concesso
a migliaia di lavoratori di scegliere
dove lavorare
e quindi di fare ritorno nelle regioni
di provenienza origine li abbiamo
contati sono più di 100.000 e
io devo un numero che ovviamente è
destinato ad aumentare
se pensiamo che faremo faremo lavoro da
remoto anche nel pos pandemia
lo ripetiamo spesso la nostra
produttività non dipende necessariamente
dalla presenza in ufficio dalle 9 alle
18 quanto piuttosto da un'organizzazione
del lavoro per obiettivi e fasi
il lavoro da remoto svolto dal sud dalle
aree interne del paese e sicuramente
una scelta che fa bene un po a tutti gli
attori coinvolti
fa bene all'azienda perché aumenta la
produttività dei singoli lavoratori
fa bene alle persone e alle famiglie
perché questo consente loro di aumentare
la qualità della vita e non da ultimo
incide anche sui territori di ritorno
che come sappiamo spesso sono
considerati marginali
quindi noi di south working diciamo
spesso che lavorare in maniera altri
della sud è una scelta che fa bene a noi
ai territori
era maggio
2020 quando ho sentito parlare per la
prima volta di south working la grande
nostalgica della mia terra e dopo un
paio di tentativi di ritorno forse
troppo prematuri ho subito pensato che
south working potesse essere la risposta
concreta per chi come me aveva sempre
desiderato fare ritorno
così mi sono unita alla community dei
supporter attraverso un gruppo facebook
ho risposto una call to action
dell'associazione e ho iniziato a
collaborare con loro a maggio 2021 a
distanza dal primo da un anno dal primo
like alla pagina instagram
ho lasciato il mio vecchio lavoro
bologna e ho trasformato il mio impegno
impegno volontario nella mio nuovo
impiego e sono tornata a vivere in
sicilia adesso il mio ufficio e make up
uno spazio di coworking del mio paese in
cui oltre a lavorare o anche il tempo di
dedicarmi a nuove progettualità per la
mia terra
a partire proprio questo e la scelta di
lavorare in un posto diverso dalla
propria sede ufficiale con l'obiettivo
di contribuire alla crescita delle
comunità dei territori nei quali si
decide di vivere e stiamo parlando dei
territori del sud e delle aree interne
del paese
south working s'impegna per la riduzione
del divario territoriale ed economico
tra le regioni più o meno sviluppate del
paese attraverso dei processi di
riattivazione di teli per i periferici e
la creazione di un nuovo capitale
sociale
ci siamo chiesti che cosa serva per fare
effettivamente south working e lo
abbiamo domandato a chi effettivamente
lo fa una striscia worker l'anno scorso
attraverso un questionario ci hanno
aiutato a delineare le tre
infrastrutture di base del south working
serve innanzitutto un infrastruttura
sociale sono luoghi lo abbiamo sentito
più volte anche questa sera luoghi di
scambio e di contaminazione e quindi non
semplici spazi di lavoro diciamo
semplici spazi di coworking servono
sicuramente quindi ricollego all'incipit
discorso
infrastrutture di mobilità servono dei
collegamenti che ci consentano di
arrivare agilmente a stazioni aeroporti
e poi da lì raggiungere le nostre sedi
di lavoro nostri clienti i nostri
colleghi e serve poi molto importante lo
strumento il nostro strumento di lavoro
un infrastruttura digitale quindi una
buona connessione che ci permetta di
lavorare in maniera efficiente e sicura
quello che però distingue davvero south
walking è quello che ne abbiamo definito
di beck e la restituzione che di
southwark le persone che decidono che
scelgono di vivere in questi luoghi
fanno le loro ai loro territori alle
loro comunità o di arrivo di primo
arrivo di ritorno e questo consiste in
nuove progettualità novi dell'impresa
nuovi avere nuove idee ma anche lo
abbiamo visto anche investimenti anche
capitali
abbiamo immaginato dei pochi ad hoc per
realizzare tutto questo
li abbiamo definiti presidi di comunità
presidi di comunità che non sono
semplicemente spazi di coworking sono
luoghi di innovazione di cambiamento in
cui avviene uno scambio tra
professionisti e anche tra generazioni
diverse perché sappiamo che sui
territori
esistono già delle energie che devono
essere necessariamente messe a sistema
i presidi di comunità si basano sulla
partecipazione dei cittadini e noi di
southwark cerchiamo sempre di metterli
in collegamento con quanto c'è già
quindi non sia i servizi di base ma
anche con le realtà culturali
associative che lavorano già sui
territori
non so se avete presente castelbuono il
borgo in borgo molto virtuoso delle
madonie proprio a castelbuono e sono na
è nato il primo presidio di comunità a
marchio esausti se così vogliamo dire ed
è nato su iniziativa di un gruppo di
ragazzi che sono tornati a lavorare nel
proprio paese dal nord italia
dall'estero che hanno utilizzato di
degli spazi messi a disposizione
dell'amministrazione comunale quindi
mettendo in moto quella diciamo quel
movimento di cui parlavamo prima
c'è chi ha chiesto diciamo c'è chi ha
parlato interloquito con
l'amministrazione comunale gli ha
procurato tavoli sedie postazioni chi ha
implementato una rete wifi ad hoc e noi
abbiamo in un certo senso supportati
nella progettazione di questi luoghi
processi che stiamo portando avanti in
tutto il sud non solo in sicilia
oggi il risultato a castelbuono è dato
da tre spazi di coworking comunali
accesso accessibili gratuitamente da
tutti di cui uno sorge all'interno di un
museo
e che sono stati già attraversati da più
di 100 persone e castelbuono un piccolo
borgo sulle madonie bisogna bisogna
ricordarlo sono sicuramente
esperimenti sono esperienze che ci fanno
immaginare soluzioni nuove a problemi
che abbiamo sempre immaginato come
diciamo irrisolvibili da queste parti e
ed è possibile grazie al ritorno di
queste persone nei loro territori
abbiamo mappato più di 230 spazi di
coworking in tutta italia
più che altro sono appunto presidi
comunità perché all'interno ci sono
anche biblioteche sedi di associazioni
quindi luoghi in cui la gente si
incontra e crea diciamo per i territori
con alcuni di questi spazi abbiamo
deciso di iniziare una sperimentazione
per la creazione di un sistema di
welfare
innovativo per la promozione della
cultura dello smart working al livello
aziendale e che mette anche a
disposizione luoghi diversi dalla
tradizionale
sede dell'ufficio ma anche diversi
dobbiamo ricordarlo dall'ufficio dal
dalla scrivania di casa nostra perché
spesso non c'è una separazione tra
l'ambiente lavorativo e l'ambiente
domestico e questo crea quello che è
stato definito l'effetto grotta
all'interno dei presidi di comunità si
cerca di dare una soluzione a tutto
questo quella sull working card abbiamo
cercato di mettere in connessione
presidi di comunità che avevano anche
bisogno di visibilità dato il periodo
che stiamo attraversando
auto worker che arrivano sui territori e
magari non sanno muoversi bene non
conoscono le persone hanno bisogno anche
di socialità e le aziende che ci stanno
contattando per chiedere soluzioni
alternative per i loro per i loro
dipendenti
e settembre il mese più nostalgico
dell'anno in cui l'estate finisce in cui
spesso si riprende l'aereo e si torna su
io quest'anno invece non ho un biglietto
in direzione nord resto a casa
certo le circostanze non sono favorevoli
e quando mai dice il testo di cronaca
montana una delle mie canzoni preferite
dei csi
il divario socio economico tra nord e
sud italia non verrà eliminato domani
non troveremo lo stesso livello di
servizi a milano di milano a riesi
leakato palermo almeno non subito però
siamo sicuri che attraverso il south
working e l'apporto dei software per
riusciremo a costruire una nuova visione
per un sud diverso da come siamo
raccontati finora un suo possibile da
cui partire solo per poi tornare
[Applauso]